et on obtient donc des données très, très incertaines.
Alors, comment peut-on détecter et corriger ces incohérences ?
Comment peut-on représenter cette forme d'incertitude ?
C'est difficile. Une chose qu'on peut faire,
c'est documenter chaque étape du processus,
non seulement en codant les informations historiques
mais aussi ce qu'on appelle les informations méta-historiques,
comment les connaissances historiques sont construites,
en documentant chaque étape.
Ça ne nous assure pas que l'on se dirige vraiment
vers une histoire unique de Venise,
mais certainement que l'on peut vraiment reconstruire
une histoire potentielle de Venise complètement documentée.
Il n'y a peut-être pas une seule carte.
Il y a peut-être plusieurs cartes.
Le système devrait nous le permettre
car on doit faire face à une nouvelle forme d'incertitude
qui est réellement nouvelle pour ce type de base de données immenses.
Comment doit-on communiquer
sur cette nouvelle recherche vers un public large ?
Encore une fois, Venise est extraordinaire en la matière.
Avec ses millions de visiteurs chaque année,
elle est vraiment un des meilleurs endroits
pour essayer d'inventer le musée de l'avenir.
Imaginez, horizontalement, on voit la carte reconstruite
d'une année donnée,
et verticalement, on voit le document
qui a permis la reconstruction,
des peintures, par exemple.
Imaginez un système immersif qui permet
d'aller, de plonger et de reconstruire la Venise d'une année donnée,
une expérience qu'on peut partager en groupe.
A l'inverse, imaginez qu'on démarre
par un document, un manuscrit vénitien,
et on montre ce qu'on peut en tirer,
comment il est décodé,
comment le contexte de ce document peut être recréé.
Voici une image d'une exposition
qui se tient actuellement à Genève
avec ce genre de système.
En conclusion, on peut dire que
la recherche dans les humanités est sur le point de subir
une évolution à peu près similaire
à ce qui s'est passé dans les sciences de la vie il y a 30 ans.
C'est en fait une question d'échelle.
On voit des projets qui sont
bien au-delà de ce qu'une seule équipe de recherche peut réaliser,
et ça, c'est vraiment nouveau dans les humanités,
où on a souvent pour habitude de travailler
en petits groupes ou seulement avec deux chercheurs.
Lorsqu'on visite les Archives d'Etat à Venise,
on sent que c'est au-delà de ce qu'une simple équipe peut réaliser,
et qu'il faut un effort partagé et commun.
Ce qu'il faut pour ce changement de modèle,
c'est promouvoir une nouvelle génération
d' « humanistes numériques »
qui seront prêts pour ce changement.
Je vous remercie beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)